what is it that Founders don't know
about the challenges of being a CEO so
the thing is with being a Founder is the
job which I've never known in any other
job the job literally flips on its head
depending on the scale of the business
and the time so it's almost like there's
peace time there's war time and then
there's scale and your approach has to
be completely different and to get a
business from zero to ten million you
essentially have to be very very
dictatorial you tell people what you
want people will tell you this isn't
going to work ignore comments you ignore
feedback and you do what the hell you
want why do you need to be dictatorial
you have no time you take high level of
risk there's no time for discussion
generally what you're trying to do
hasn't been done before there's no data
to back up what you're thinking you need
to grow quick okay in that period there
were several times that we risked
everything we had to get to that next
level